[Music]  Horford wide open space it goes by Noah  takes it to the basket junior little  pump fake look at Crowder  he's porzingis comes over give me a  tomahawk  there you go  [Music]  the Celtics down for a great pack star  [Applause]  [Music]  to the basket  now before that lay up like Kevin Durant  Oklahoma City shooting 31% half of that  how about that fast  and cut James wanted a foul play  Thompson rushes up the floors Durant  quickly chili biscuit went the party  Irving the TriCaster change  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  Jackson above crumbs of down over  Stoudemire  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  in transition wave spreads  ratbat put it under your Christmas tree  mostly up against play Thompson its  Jefferson  [Music]  everybody Richard